i was driving home from the comedy store
one night which is where i perform when
i'm in l.a
it was about one in the morning on a
wednesday night and so
you guys doesn't mean anything to you
but when i drive home i live off of
ventura boulevard and
near my house ventura boulevard is like
four lanes wide and it's straight
and when i drive home at one in the
morning on a wednesday nobody's on the
road
so i'll always light a joint two miles
from my house why two miles from my
house i appreciate you asking
because through a lot of trial and error
i have found that two miles
takes three songs
right and at the end of three songs
third song i'm pulling it into my
driveway
and that's when the weed is really
hitting me it's science guys it's
science right
so i feel good three songs two miles
pull into the driveway you're high
so i hit the two mile mark and i i i
light up my joint i roll up the windows
i'm hot boxing myself
and um i'm picking i decide i'm gonna
listen to three allman brothers songs
right
and so i'm picking them out i'm picking
them out picking them out
i pick out the third song and uh i
let a huge puff of smoke i know i'm
gonna be super high
and i look up and i see a sign that says
you are now
entering a dui checkpoint and i was like
oh no no no no no no
no no no no now what's my first instinct
turn around do you know why i didn't do
that
for sure the cops have thought of that
do you know what i mean like
there's no way you can get out of a dui
by doing this
well i don't want to drive over there
that's not going to get you out of the
ticket you know so i'm like i just gotta
drive through
so i roll down the windows i get a
little air tornado going you know what i
mean
and um i get in a long line of cars and
at the other end of the line there's a
police officer
and he's either pulling people over or
he's letting them go through
so i'm waiting in line and waiting in
line and one song goes by and i'm like
oh no
tick tock tick tock everybody you know
what i mean at the end of that third
song i'm going to [ __ ] jail if i am
still in this line
so i'm sitting there i'm getting nervous
middle of the line
second song ends and i'm like and by the
way guys it's not that i'm not used to
being in line when i'm high
but there's usually a [ __ ] burrito at
the other end of the line you know what
i mean
not some dude who's going to ruin my
life you know
checking checking check-in second song
ends
i go up to the front there's one car in
front of me third song ends
and i'm as high as i'm gonna be which is
pretty high
third song ends but he lets this woman
go through
and i was like oh [ __ ] there's hope
he's letting people go through so
anybody by the way and anybody who's
ever been high or high in front of a cop
or high driving you'll understand this
there's hope
so all i'm thinking
all i'm thinking when i'm pulling over
the cop all i'm thinking the entire time
is
just don't look high
i was practicing my not high face in the
rear view i was like
you know doing a little uh
i was trying to look as cool as i could
you know but for whatever and i landed
on a face that i thought for sure was
going to keep me out of jail
but for whatever reason when i pulled up
to the cop that's not the face that came
out
when i pulled up the cop i went like
this
like i went full force gump on this dude
hey lieutenant dan
you know and he just goes can you pull
it over for me
i please it over right and he walks up
to the car and he goes
you roll down the window please i said
yes sir and i'm not kidding guys
like i like i roll it down maybe an
inch maybe an itch i just kind of lean
back and i go how are you tonight
and because it was the only thing he
could fit in my car
dude stuck his lips in my window
and he goes just like this he goes can
you roll it down a little more for me
please right
now look guys i'm high right so all he's
got is his lips in my window which means
the top half of his face is over my car
all i can see is his mouth moving like
this and when you're high i don't care
who it is that's [ __ ] funny right
so this dude is talking to me like this
and i'm sitting in the front seat like
and i just see him go roll out the
[ __ ] window and i was like yeah
you're right you're right
uh you're right
i rolled down the window and as soon as
i rolled down the window
my man stuck his head in my car like a
[ __ ] velociraptor he was all
and he just started sniffing my face
just
and i was freaking the [ __ ] out
for sure he could see the heartbeat in
the side of my neck like
legging right you know when you can feel
your heart beating every orifice
you know when your [ __ ] has a
heartbeat you know what i'm talking
about
that's when you know you're scared when
your asshole's like get us out of here
you know
so i thought i was going to jail like
for sure
but as quickly as he stuck his head in
my car he took it out
and he said well you don't smell like
alcohol and marijuana
and i said uh i don't
i was genuinely surprised i'm not gonna
lie to you i was legitimately surprised
i had just been smoking weed in this car
50 feet ago
how do i not smell like weed i'm not
gonna lie to you i was a little mad at
the dude who sold me the weed
i'm like this is some punk-ass [ __ ] i
should smell like weed right now
but he can being a police officer he
kind of caught on to my question
and he said do you think you should
smell like it and i said no sir no sir i
was just at the comedy store
and sometimes when you walk through the
crowd somebody might spill a beer on you
or something
and i said and i hang out in the parking
lot and you know and all the other
comics smoke weed
oh i'm throwing everybody under the bus
i don't give a [ __ ]
guess who's not going to jail your boy
he goes yeah he goes you don't smell
like it and he said plus your eyes look
fine and i was thinking to myself
well you're pretty bad at your job man i
i don't feel safe driving through this
checkpoint to tell you the truth
i don't know who you let through ahead
of me you're not good at your job
i don't feel safe with you on the road
i'll tell you what and then i started to
think
how are they going to dui test us
stoners
how i want to show you guys okay pay
attention
[Applause]
been smoking weed since noon
[Applause]
dexterity is not our issue
we fool pretty easily i mean you could
trick us you know what i mean
if he wanted to bust me for dui it would
have been way easier
he should have just walked up to the car
and been like how you doing tonight
pretty good sir how are you
great you had any alcohol marijuana no
sorry i'm not
you done anything to impair your ability
to operate a motor vehicle
no sir i have not great well before i
let you go
just wanted to let you know that
there is a sandwich on the hood of your
[Music]
car
what kind of sandwich
[Music]
[Music]
you